c'est une décision radicale le
gouvernement italien vient d'annoncer la
fermeture des écoles et universités dans
tout le pays à partir de ce jeudi et
jusqu'au 15 mars
une option décidé lors d'un conseil des
ministres réuni à rome
autour du président du conseil guissepe
compter comme vous le savez la décision
de fermer dans les écoles a fait l'objet
d'une évaluation continue et pour le
gouvernement cela n'a pas été une
décision facile
nous avons attendu l'avis du comité
scientifique et technique et nous avons
décidé avec prudence puisque la
situation épidémiologique rapidement de
suspendre les activités éducatives en
dehors de la leçon mordu jusqu'au 15
mars
une mesure similaire existe déjà depuis
une dizaine de jours dans le nord de
l'italie
la région la plus affectée par
l'épidémie ou une ville en vénétie et 10
en lombardie ont été placées en zone
rouge sous quarantaine dans la ville de
cremo n'est pas de quarantaine mais une
tente installée devant l'hôpital
l'objectif gérer l'arrivée des personnes
souffrant de symptômes du coronavirus à
l'intérieur longue blouse bleue masque
filtrant sur le nez mains protégées par
des gants en plastique et couvre chefs
sur la tête
deux membres du personnel accueille les
malades ici nous faisons a relevé des
paramètres température corporelle check
list pour savoir depuis quand ce patient
à ses symptômes et ce qu'il représente
exactement ces éléments sont relevées
par deux agents sanitaires expert en
triage le gouvernement italien également
adopter de nouvelles mesures tous les
matchs de football auront lieu à huis
clos les salons conférences et congrès
seront reportés en particulier dans le
secteur de la santé de manière à libérer
au maximum le personnel sanitaire
[Musique]